all right for people joining this live
stream
we are talking about incremental
language development
as we head into version 12.2 of of
language so we are trying to finish off
a bunch of things here
and that means we're writing a bunch of
documentation
um and
let's take a look at axiomatic theory so
what did we conclude last time we
concluded that we're on a glyph hunt
is that right that we're going to find
some new gloves to put in here is that
correct
you mean for the formal operators yes
yes
i understand but but do you know what's
happened um
um uh let's see
um
um
gosh
okay so are these these ones that
um
so so we have marked the ones that are
new and then
there are a few on which manu is still
working
and i think we will be able to add them
what is that one two operational logic
axioms what was that one
um it's from nks it's just a single
axiom
that um uses only um
either um and or and not
did i say where i got it from
no but i found a a reference from
a little bit before nks was published
okay
um
well hold on let me look at that one is
that
i have to find out whether that was the
um
you know what page that's on
i'm checking okay
there i've pasted it in chat it's one of
the notes
the last one
okay yeah that was not mine
um
do you have the actual reference did you
did you um
yeah it looks like it's mccoon at all
a bunch of argon guys
okay well i think we should call it
or not
because it's a minimal axiom i mean it's
a i'm not actually i'm not sure if it is
minimal
um
[Music]
and that's just where we get into
trouble with it with our naming scheme
do you mean because you wanted also a
person
well not necessarily but i mean it just
um
um
i mean because we're not saying some of
these things are boolean algebra
right
well in principle we have separated the
logic
related from the more mathematics
related
no i know but when we say you know
tasky algorithm our axioms
then tarsky also had axioms for
hilbert's
you know for geometry right right that's
the excluded node further down
which which doesn't fall into any of
these two categories
so we were not sure where to put it
it's fundamentally different from the
rest well and also
i mean one issue is i think this naming
scheme that we have
is hmm
hmm
we could have a structure of alternate
standard names like it's done
multiple times in other places
right where it's like person what it's
an axiom for
axioms i mean the word axioms is a
little bit redundant here although
that will allow us to um um by the way
jose apparently you are too quiet
on um on the livestream is that your
wonderful new microphone that i insisted
you get
and now it's too quiet not yet no this
is my old one
well then then you're too quiet right so
okay so i try to change to about the
volume
try to what increase or decrease
increase
increase increase yes okay
um all right so
i do think we're gonna end up going to
okay first point is
are we going to put these axioms in a
repository what should we decide about
that
i don't think so i think the idea was to
have special documentation pages for
them but
still get them here okay
why again don't we want them in a
repository
um i don't know to me they are kind of
small
to deserve to be in our ripple
well but they're not going to be small
when we start adding to this
just a gazillion you know things from
all these formalized mathematics systems
i mean look what we can't put in here
is you know a random i don't know
spinoza's
ethics axioms or something right we're
not gonna by the time we're doing that
we're gonna have you know the dining
philosopher's axioms and things like
this
which is going to get crazy i see
um
mano what did we what did we discuss
previously about this
do you recall i i don't think we've
directly discussed putting them
in a repository okay
so the reason we didn't do that
previously
was that we were concerned that this
scheme is renaming the operators right
but i don't think that that's
inconsistent with it being in a
repository because as soon as we
list the operators we can
trivially do this when we
sort of pull them out of the repository
now the advantage of putting them in a
repository
i mean the advantage is it becomes a lot
easier to add them
and i i'm concerned
you understand what when we're looking
at adding all these things from these
formalized mathematics systems
how are we going to bring them in
because we're going to have
um
you know in a sense okay
we have two kinds of things we have
what we might think of as base axioms
and then what we might think of as kind
of set up
for some particular type of thing that
makes sense like like a
well for example for a particular group
do we have the
do we have things set up in axiomatic
theory now to be able to deal with the
the um
relations of a particular group yes
yes is that documented here
um yes i think so under examples no
no
okay all right
and there are a couple of examples on
how to use this in
in in find the customer proof
other examples here of um
so find it find equation of proof has
probably examples of like syllogisms and
things
right yes so that example you are
looking at in the middle no
no a bit up the first one in your page
right now that one
is with the quaternions equation group
well that's nice what would be the
default if i didn't give multiplication
arrow p inverse zero whatever what would
it look like
the standard i think sequel times
try to move it here
what the heck is that goodness
this must be the the new addition
of um the dataset property
um we fixed well we fixed that yesterday
so perhaps which version is this
that's really ancient a few days ago
yeah so well we have fixed that
but um okay
all right anyway all right but so so
that
is uh that would be
the the okay all right look look the
general comment and then we need to move
on from this for 12.2
but you know this whole theorem proving
subsystem
is becoming a more significant thing as
we can tell by
you know all these functions are
becoming more complicated i
you know i feel like
how to think about this right because i
mean we
you know by the time we've got specific
groups here we've also got what about
specific i mean nano you did this
translation
of the um uh uh
you know the tarsky based um
uh you know that that proving some of
euclid's element you know euclid's
uh theorems from the tarsky axiom system
right and that has several pieces to it
so in addition to
the base tasky stuff you also have to
define you know
and i have a circle in this position
which is basically
like you know what on earth is that like
here is that like
because that's not a that's not a
theorem that follows from the axioms
that's a new piece of information that
you're adding or making sense
so it's like a new axiom
like a postulate yes
yes well it's a it's a
you know look what do we mean by
accidents what do you mean by postulates
i mean we're saying
there exists there exists two circles on
the page that's just like
saying there exists an operator with
these properties and so i'm trying to
understand as we have this axiomatic
theory thing
we're going to have to you know what
we're going to need is some kind of
compiler
from for example the geometric
i'm get very confused here um the
synthetic geometry group is working on
something they call
find um
geometric statements
well no they've got yes that's the thing
which given
a setup will find true facts
in that setup exactly yes
and the idea is to make it work via this
framework too
so it will return a proof object etc
yes you know okay
we probably um
uh
yeah we we probably need um um
i mean we're going to need another
discussion about formalized mathematics
i mean i think
um okay let's look at the specific
things you want to do here
so i think we already agreed on all of
these things here
and why those future eyes are they not
really futurized
well the ones that are in red have been
added already to the system okay other
ones
uh manu is still working on them and
they will be added in the next few days
so the main thing here is to make sure
that you agree with the names of the
properties and names of the theories and
the explanations
logic type what's that going to return
so there's either equational
general predicate or axiom schema
it depends on how the axiom system works
with find equational proof
i see okay
and how do you feed in the logic type to
find equation proof
i'm using entity classes right now um
and i'm going to uh find a way to
calculate a property from that
so hold on a second but yeah i think
steven didn't mean that so so the idea
is that
the logic is kind of obvious in what you
write
in the actions now this logic is not the
logic we will use
to prove it so that's why we distinguish
the input logic of the theorems from the
logic
that is used to prove them which is
always equational
you can test whether the the main
predicate is equal
that's pretty straightforward what about
if there's some that are equal and some
that are not
then the tree it treats the whole thing
as predicate
because then it needs axioms for the
equals then doesn't it which it wouldn't
otherwise need
right right but but the point being you
can you can always prove equational
theorems from predicate logic but you
can't always prove predicate theorems
from equation or logic
or from equational axioms i should say
right but does it automatically add in
the equation all i mean
where are for example here we probably
need
something that says equational axioms
yes that are the axioms
until we have the formal equals
predicate there isn't really a way to do
that
i mean like it works algorithmically it
doesn't work from a typesetting
standpoint
because the equal sign right evaluates
in ways that are unpleasant
exactly
and did we agree on the last time when
we were talking about glow hunting
did we agree what we're going to do for
the equal sign
in terms of its alternate glyph
i don't think so but for example manu
what is the
symbol you are using for field axioms
i was trying to use dot equals but um
i'm running into some problems with that
um
it's not working with find equational
proof as i expected
well does dot equal have some built-in
properties
not to my knowledge so it isn't
associated for example
i don't think so right
[Music]
um
okay listen we don't want to take up
this meeting for this too much but but
let's
all right so logic type is just a string
in this case is that right
yeah probably should be an entity at
some point in the future
okay by the way are we really calling it
axiom schema
i think it's just going to be higher
order logic or
something like that yeah that should be
the name should be a higher order should
be second order what what does it
i don't know the what's the right thing
there
uh well from a theorem proving
standpoint it doesn't matter because
once the higher order logic theorem
proving stuff is in system
uh it will be able to deal with anything
using the same algorithmic techniques
find equational proof won't care whether
it's second order or third order
it's just a question of whether we want
to distinguish
yes
um but yeah and until we have that
meeting about for all i can't proceed
with that
so wait wait wait what was the point
before all
we need to stop for all stripping out
predicates which i thought we were going
to discuss in this meeting but it seems
why aren't we discussing it why don't we
just do it
is there any reason not to do it i think
adam is the keeper of for could somebody
see if they can find adam
we can have that discussion here yeah i
can try to grab him
so you're saying the problem is that for
all f of x
what do you say for all f f of x
fails in some way yeah
that's freaking say why does it do that
well it kind of makes sense i mean
forall i guess was designed to quantify
over variables
well don't know why it makes sense
because i mean what would this otherwise
mean
you're quantifying over a variable that
doesn't get used
so it's equivalent to just i see so the
question of usage is really just a
question of heads goes to all in the
usage checker
and then it will it will block this one
right it's probably just doing a free
queue of some kind
there's nothing in the documentation
that says it shouldn't work
i think it's just a bug let's get it
fixed
um
okay so let's just go through this as i
say
logic type eventually should be an
entity in my opinion
okay ancillary definitions what are
those those are those are
operators that are useful ancillary
operators like for example
in the case of that's defining something
like
and how did we agree that that's
defining things like
when you have the minimal group well we
have nand for example it's defining and
or
not in terms of nand right
yeah so i've just made sure that all of
the boolean logic
systems uh have and or not nand
defined okay
okay um
why don't you i mean while you're at it
why don't you do xor and nor
as well i mean the named and i mean
you know they're easy to get right why
don't you why don't we put them in that
seemed useful
yeah i was planning on it but i think um
we're gonna need
new glyphs for those um the ones that
are currently there
i think they have uh built-in meanings
i see so this is a glyph hunt again
okay all right
okay
i think we should call this
or not boolean exims
okay
um
now are you going to give the operators
the list of operators for some of these
other ones or not
perhaps not it's too complicated i think
those are what will go on the subsidiary
documentation page so those ones like
equivalential calculus
those come from nks is that right or are
they what where are they what are those
no i think yeah yeah okay are they
non-minimal are they are they
are they for humans are there or are
they minimal ones
i think they're for humans they have
easily nameable
axioms for the most part okay fine
all right what on earth is the meadow
theory what is
meadow theory oh it's just uh
something cool i found it's uh basically
an alternative to fields
but it's completely uh equational
okay well it's documentation page what a
stupid name meadow
anyway never mind it's funny posture
theory um the
uh
it's like a physicist who's a friend of
mine
named rick field who's whose sister
actually is a
well-known actress named sally field
and um uh sally field was quoted at some
point as saying that she
and she perfectly well knew that this
wasn't the correct thing but that
that she gathered that her brother had
invented this thing called field theory
okay that's supposed to be funny never
mind
um i'm sure we can find that quote
somewhere on the web
uh a different field theory the the
quantum field third kind
okay never mind um
okay can we not put in this tasky stuff
i'm i'm having some problems with the
operators i need to talk to jonathan
about this
what's wrong with them because we don't
have glyphs so for some other reason
i just don't know why dot equal isn't
working um and find equational proof i
think the way i've
written the axioms is correct but you
know
they need to so the problem is that when
when we've used this before we we've
just used symbols
that are arbitrary system symbols right
which we don't want to use here
that's the whole want to use some kind
of operator form
um okay
all right well it's pretty we can't get
that in for now but
we're not gonna get it in right now so
okay
uh did we manage to find adam for the
for all discussion
i couldn't get a hold of him tried
calling him and i sent him a couple of
notes
but okay but so let's just ask him to
see if he can't just like fix that bug i
think it's just a bug let's see if he
can fix it
can you push that please devin yeah yeah
i got it
um and if there's a problem with that he
should send mail about it
okay okay anything else
for this here why is this in red
i think it's just to mark that it's
special syntax
okay fine oh you just joined us
okay adam can you explain why this
doesn't work and can we make it work
ah let me see okay
for all like yeah we just want it to not
evaluate
oh uh
right so it interprets f as a variable
so it doesn't look at variables and
heads of things
right so you just have to fix that
that's all we're asking okay
okay okay
um and we might want to add one line to
the documentation about that
okay that was very easy guys look at how
easy that was jonathan
yeah just doesn't think about yeah
no no we didn't name quantification over
function names uh
can you do something with it yes that's
the whole point
jonathan you want to say something about
that uh yeah uh basically
we're using it to represent higher order
logics so
where you would conventionally have an
axiom an axiom schema we want to be able
to quantify over predicates to represent
those axiom schemas as second order
propositions but that requires being
able to quantify over predicates which
right now we can't do
right okay so so are there
algorithms for for the delinquent or
it's just for representing things
there there is an algorithm for dealing
with it it's it works it's not great
but it works so for simple cases
maybe did do you have that in the in the
function repository yet
jonathan the the um i do not know but it
but
it's but it's in the dropbox heading for
the function representing
the physics dropbox somewhere yeah um
let's just show adam for a second just
to just to is it a not ready
uh get where it is it's in jg
graph drafts find higher order logic
proof
that's the one
all right so this claims to be if we run
find higher
logic proof
so what what did you have here this this
is one where you can't do it because of
the um
well so so i'm as you can see i'm using
hold form
to stop for all from evaluating oh okay
so that's yeah for all f
uh-huh right exactly so it's saying
basically here we're just going to say
every predicate every
binary predicate you see is commutative
so f of x y equals f y x for all
f um and then you're and then using that
commutativity we're going to prove
something oh nice
okay i'll fix it then that's oh yeah
here's a more interesting example which
is an induction
schema so if you know for all predicates
phi if
5x is true then five successor of x is
true
ah
right why is this coming out as proof
objects which
look like garbage uh because proof
object higher order logic
isn't uh that we don't have a make boxes
rule for that
i'm gonna add one but okay
but so if i say this here is some proof
graph
it'll probably do the right thing i
think so
no it doesn't oh well okay
um the logic needs needs to be
registered
right what do you mean the logic needs
to be registered
that the system has a logic q somewhere
and
and if it doesn't recognize yet that
logic then some things will not work
like the summary box i see okay
all right well okay we're going to be
having a subsequent discussion about
more of this formalized mathematics
stuff
um uh but okay adam will fix that
terrific do it let's just see whether we
need to make a change to the for all
documentation page
to refer to that
um okay so
you may need to make some small change
here adam
propose i'll check it
whether it's okay use this okay
okay thanks adam yeah sure bye bye
um okay
let's go on i think that was everything
for for asthmatic theory is that correct
guys
yep i think so okay great so mano and
jonathan can depart if they wish to do
so
and we will go on with our next items
thanks
all right so now we have the four echo
functions
which we have looked at several times
but the pages are still futurised
okay i thought we i mean how are we
finished with these did we
is there anything about these designs
that we're not happy with
no i i think it's all fine we have tried
to
knit them a bit but i think okay
so you want to you want me to hit the
defuturize button basically
yes it's some final yes approval and say
okay are we thinking they're
experimental i don't think they're
particularly experimental
i'm not worried about them no i don't
think so what do you think again
um echo timing i think is supposed to
remain experimental
because of the method option
okay that
relative for cpu versus absolute timing
right okay
okay and then we've got to do some
knitting
um
gosh quiet echo is probably got a yet
another piece of semantic horror
with um um
uh what is quiet echo again
it's a way to disable of the eco family
oh i see that's that's harmless enough
um yeah it's useful yeah because now we
all use echo multiple
times so it's good to be able to disable
them all
okay uh shouldn't that have
something like you know abort protect as
a related
why work well
similar idea of stopping a function from
[Music]
acting
i don't think so i think that will be
confusing to people
okay um all right let's look at the uh
uh guide pages
for these where where have you put them
in terms of guide pages
well let's look at where i have to go oh
my gosh my elephant has been retired
um for searching these things
um echo timing refer to timing
as related sure should yes um
wait a minute does that have a c also
yes it does require
for referred timing
now timing should probably refer to
timing and absolute timing so on they
need to refer to echo timing
right i think we didn't do the back
knitting
yes okay
i don't know how i missed the timing in
the echo timing
see also i think it's
see also blindness could be um
okay now these ones
um did you do the the back the the um
seal sewing between echo and echo
label and all that kind of stuff yes
okay but the out of echo stuff isn't
exactly
this quiet or the other guide pages
i i added some tentative
knitting to guide pages that are in chat
okay
all right let me look at those in a
second um
yeah a quiet echo needs to go at the end
here because it's really a different
thing um
uh let's let's also have
um does print point print probably
points to echo right
but it doesn't point to any of the other
things
by the way we don't have any kind of
echo temporary do we
temporary no
that's an interesting idea
right okay let's look at guide page
stuff here
um
okay so we've got time measurement and
optimization
we've got tuning and debugging
and we've got basic input and output and
programs
boy why are these made so small why are
they there why are they
okay echo function
that seems okay
oh for goodness sake why is this tagged
for 12 1
could you let the documentation people i
don't know that i can fix that
[Music]
why is this defaulting this is crazy why
is this defaulting to 12
1. don't know
and and why is it saying twelve one plus
anyway it should be a twelve one
whatever
um and and by the way that is clearly
wrong that should be
um devin can you point that out to
documentation people that should be a
italic string i don't know how to do
that here yep yeah i got it
um
hmm
well this is a weird page anyway
i guess it's okay to list all of these
here
what is that core value oh yeah i know
what that does
um you know what echo evaluation should
point to it should point
to in out and it should point
to
probably it should point to
dialogue
because it's simulating in-out behavior
right
right the idea of in out is very good
yes not so sure about dialogue because
there is no interactivity here
[Music]
wait a minute are you editing this page
this wait what's happening here
oh gosh don't tell me this is being
pulled up in both
versions here oh no
okay bit of a disaster there
why what happened i had two different
versions open
and they stepped on each other
that should be okay
well with the recording we can
reconstruct
in case it's needed yeah hopefully it
won't be needed
okay i i want to come back to this
page um
you know what i don't like this let's
let's actually write
right why we're doing this here um
oops
print an expression
how are we going to say this and return
the expression
we would just say that print and return
and return an expression
okay now how do we describe some of
these other things
um which other ones do we think are
important here in my opinion the second
one is second timing
and probably the third echo evaluation
with functional label being just
operator forms of echo
yeah i don't think those are so
important for this page
those are more sophisticated things
right
so what i mean is right now i see myself
using echo i mean a lot but maybe that's
not for this page
oh i see yeah it will be better in there
in the tuning
right echo evaluation is more for this
page i think
that's about it for this page in my
opinion
okay
okay now let's go to the next page
um
now this robustness and error handling
page which is new
is all about confirm and so on
and this says code monitoring print an
intermediate result
so i think there
we should add
um at least a um
let's just add echo timing
and echo evaluation and echo timing
and maybe echo echo function here
maybe these echo label all of that's
that's the whole family right
uh yes there's quiet deco i know we
don't need to add that here
this is not rolling to this page
um
okay now
tuning and debugging
does that now point to the the um
okay hold on
all right oh my god
you got to tell these guys it's wrong so
i'm sorry if somebody sets this
correctly i will get it right otherwise
i'm not going to get it right
um
all right
i'm not sure this is right to list all
these and look at look at the rest of
this page
okay there's no way this page is the is
the key page for this
what was the other one
actually this really isn't right
well
maybe it is i think
the debugging the scenario of debugging
is the one in which
all the echo functions are used most
okay
okay
all right that's what looks okay
okay anything else here
uh no i don't think so okay
so the next two are functions
here oh that's that one
okay
let me just check echo evaluation check
we didn't mess something up there
that looks fine
okay right next fold while foldwell list
yes so these are another two pages that
we looked at
already
and are there potential issues with this
did we solve the problem of what does it
do
in in certain corner cases
right so there are the final arguments
and here we follow
next while same right type of structure
you think it's we're done here right
yeah i think so
okay did we net it um probably not
there are two guide pages called
functional programming and functional
iteration
which why aren't we pointing this to
things like
take while isn't take while relevant to
this
um it's not exactly
yeah it's similar yes we could certainly
what the heck is sequence fault why do i
not even remember it exists
yeah so this is the fault variant of the
sequence family
my god you see this is upsetting because
you know it's like this is what happens
if you introduce these functions 30
years later is you just don't remember
they exist
but this is particularly i mean this is
not that old
i know it's not that old yeah so these
yeah right this is the multi-argument
folding story
in which you have a prefix that can be
any number of
of things here
i see and then you're starting to fold
in the things
[Music]
after the prefix you start to fold
things in right
so in full while there is also an
argument
of number of variables that you feed to
the test function
so it's separate it's different so it's
not to the function being applied but to
the test i understand by the way
atom on our live stream is asking why
does quiet echo behave globally
why not have echo disable echo enable
because quiet echo is a wrapper
right it's for functional programming so
it's you wrap it around
things and everything that is in its sub
you know
if you if you want to there's no way to
unquiet given that you put the rapper
quiet echo
around something there is no way to have
in other words if i say
if i say echo
um let's say i say echo evaluation two
plus four okay
now i say quiet echo
that i'll just get that but there's no
way that i can
i mean i could put echo evaluation in
here
um
right so what i expect okay hold on let
me try to understand this
oh my god this is so difficult to
understand
do we have is there any possibility of a
jump down link
here what do you mean
did i click on that and it goes down
here
oh um perhaps we would
have to do some dynamic something there
i'm not sure we'd have to be dynamic we
should let's ask the front end team
whether there's any possibility of that
or any possibility of having it light up
or something
okay because that would seem quite
useful to me i mean the fact that i had
to think about mouse over
so the 13 or the 11.
and it shows me what the input was yep
that's useful does it say that in
documentation anywhere
no i can add that
um that's nice i didn't know that
right what is the is that is that input
form that it's showing in the in the
tool tip
we probably want to make sure it's
standard form in the tool tip
should be standard form okay
oh yeah looks fine
um okay i'm i'm gonna have to go soon
let me just see how
are we doing on the meeting um agenda
okay fold wildfold while this did we did
we knit those do we know how they're
knitting
there are two natural guide pages one is
called
functional programming the other is
functional iteration
that's a bit disappointing that we have
summary oh
in 12 2 wait a minute fold while
oh yeah that's because it's new
perfect
okay functional iteration
it would go
under presumably under here right
i think so
and um
okay what's the right way to describe
this uh
fold
while a criterion is true
while the condition is satisfied
actually is to be
do you think that's the right place for
it or should it go above the sequence
faults
and so on
um i don't know they are all
equivalently important perhaps
we put it before because it's newer so
it gets more probably sitting
no no in another three years it won't be
newer
right okay
no i think it's fine yep okay not sure
whether
it's a condition it's more like a test
so it's not an expression that has to be
true it's uh
it's a function that gets applied isn't
that how take while and lengthwise work
as well
yes i think so okay okay fine
just to be consistent with a warning
right
i kind of think we should just replace
one of these we just say sequence fold
sequence hold this fold pair
and then fold
while what do you think and then you go
to the sub page to see the list versions
okay
okay now um can somebody else
knit these could you knit them onto the
back knitting
places where they need to do back
knitting okay so we had just have a
chance to look at that last
gender item right
oh boy is this horrifying well we
started the discussion of how to
represent
leap days and uh we have asked some some
people
from india and china how do they do
things
so these are the options that we see as
most
reasonable
okay so i mean
clearly the word leap isn't going to
make it as a
as a rapper like that i mean if we're
going to do that it should be something
like a leap
date or something or leap
do they call them leaps
each language will use a different name
but um
i think the general concept is being lip
lip day lip month
lip weak the problem is that it's it's a
grand rarity the the thing is that lip
ground reality
but it sounds very technical
so what about the idea having a string
instead of of a single not like that
no i i think we should have a okay hold
on
okay let's look at the cases where this
occurs
so so if i say
i don't understand yes this is an
example in which both
there are both leap months that's the
second column and leap days that's
the third column
okay leap day i understand what women
what is it
is february 29th leap day
yes that's a leap day but would i wrap
it and leap
or what would i say for would i say leap
of 28th
just represent the 29th or what would i
do i mean
we could have used that convention it's
just that we invented the new convention
of
having a different number because it
happens once every few every four years
so it's not very frequent
but here in these calendars any day can
be leap
but a leap means an extension of the
a a new copy of the day exactly i repeat
it
it's a it's an it's two consecutive
names with the same
two consecutive days with the same name
and why not why can't it be three
consecutive days
or five consecutive days because this
happens
in things that get slightly synchronized
desynchronized like a lunar day is
slightly
smaller than a solar day and that
happens
every few weeks it will happen that
you have to right but you you'll never
get it far off enough i mean back in
antiquity people had you know
half years that they added and
subtracted right
yes but they wouldn't call it leap they
may have some
it's a generalized leap okay so what
this is is a
um
yeah it's it's it's like like when you
have in the streets
they introduce a new door and they put
the same number as the previous one with
a b
so we are looking for equivalent of that
b here
right
the main question is whether we denote
all days with true or false
which is what is being done here no way
or we just reserve
something for the leap ones yeah reserve
something for the leap ones
like leap variant
um
but does it always follow does it always
is it always that
the leap variant is always the following
of the i mean leap variant of three
means
that the redoubling of three is that
correct
yes but it's true that in some cases
they may decide that the first one is
the elite one
and not the second one
so maybe what we should do is leap
variant three comma two
means that everything could have a leap
variant but the default leap variant or
three comma one
the default leap variant
sleep bearing is the offset i see
so that's the offset it's the it's the
base number and then it's an offset
and so leap variant comma zero
would default back to just three
okay and so
if we could use lip three
lip variant of three that's the first
lip
and if needed to have more we would just
add the
comma two comma three exactly
lead variant of leap variant of three
would be leap bearing to three comma one
right lead variant three comma zero
would be just three
um and leap variant of three comma minus
one
would be some kind of bizarre version of
where the hiccup is added before the
thing
i see okay because that gives
information of what is the
true one before or after exactly
that might be useful yeah like that
brian is asking are there leap seconds
leap minutes yes there
are i mean there aren't leap minutes
in the modern world right
yes lip second the standard thing is
rather than
59 to be the last one they call it 60
the last one
so that mean it goes to from 0 to 60
comma
999
yeah which we could handle with this
leap variant idea i like leapparent
i mean it's pretty obscure concept but
it's still
i mean and that means that leap variant
of 28 february 28th
should just work you know the variant of
28th should work
for the regular calendar okay
um nick
any comments on this no i think i think
it's a pretty good
solution here that lets us adapt it for
you know there aren't very many
calendars that
have complications or we'd need a
multiple offset
but it's good to future proof against
that and
you said you could have leap variant
just normalize out
you know if you said leap variant of the
third during a gregorian day we'd know
it's just oh you mean the fourth day
but right we already have a
normalization routine for those things
so i think it's it's fairly
descriptive and it gives us a ref page
to talk specifically about these
fun complicated cases so i mean i think
look by the way you say future proofing
it's really past proofing
yeah complexity proofing i guess right
of of uh
let's see if we can get the babylonians
covered by this
yeah we had a bit of a discussion with
christopher about that and it's
definitely complicated and i've been
working on the japanese calendar which
has some similar complications with
adopting and then dropping and then
adding back in and blank periods
and far future far past so we've we're
definitely covering a lot of complicated
cases already which gives us
hope for dealing with really nuanced
calendars in the future
right um
sounds good all right we should wrap up
here by the way for people in the live
stream who are interested we will be
talking about machine learning
at the top of the next hour um
and uh off i go to something completely
different
all right thanks guys i just pushed the
uh the documentation updates
they should be showing up i'm direct